on a avec nous mathieu louvain ce membre
du conseil national des républicains et
vous vous allez voter pour eric zemmour
va nous dire pourquoi un instant et
stéphane durbec alors stéphane c'est
vraiment un très très proche si vous
étiez très proche du front national on
se rappelle de vous moi je me rappelle
très bien de stéphane ah si si on vous a
vu souvent en photo avec jean marie le
pen c'est vrai et aujourd'hui vous êtes
toujours proche de jean-marie le pen
mais aujourd'hui soutien d'eric zemmour
je ne suis pas proche j'ai gardé j'ai
pas de contact avec jean-marie le pen ou
front national + moi donc je suis
adhérent j'ai soutenu dès 2012 nicolas
sarkozy donc je ne suis plus au fond de
ton ami au rassemblement national et je
vais vous dire tout simplement pourquoi
parce qu'on a considéré que ma place il
ya près de cinq ans et devait se situer
à fond de cale donc si ça me donne le
bon positionnement vis-à-vis du front
national dont on ne peut pas dire je
sais ça qu'est ce qui s'est passé ou non
si vous les comptes vous avez quelqu'un
qui dit dans un propos que votre place
est à fond de cale et qu'on me compare
pas ce que vous avez un parcours
militaire qui est le mien et j'en suis
fier et je leur dis pas et qu on vous
compare à
pabos qassam et mobutu et c'était
bizarre bobek donc si vous laissez là
c'est du genre c'est plus agréable et ça
démontre en fait la vraie nature donc
c'est quelque chose qui ne manie pas moi
par contre aujourd'hui ce qui m'anime
avec zemmour c'est toujours la même
passion de cette france là volonté de la
servir la volonté on sent qu'à travers
le récit le propos il ya l'amour de
cette france profonde il ya l'amour des
régions il ya l'amour du terroir il ya
l'amour du de la langue et puis c'est le
même parcours ce que beaucoup de gens
oublient alors on dit que c'est d'abord
un écrivain c'est pas le polémiste vous
dites que en tout cas là le cas entre
guillemets pour dire du bien dit que
c'est un polémiste non c'est un auteur
c'est un écrivain à succès et je crois
que ça fait ça parle aux français ça
parle d'un électorat ce qui est à la
fois les déçus de défi de fillon les
désabusés de marine le pen au regard de
son de son débat du deuxième tour on se
demande encore aujourd'hui comment elle
peut prétendre à la présidence de la
république et puis un nouvel électorat
qui est un électorat qui va être cherché
à mon avis qui va ce qui se manifeste
déjà qui est dans les absentionnistes ce
que tout le monde oublie aujourd'hui
c'est que le premier quand ce sont les
abstentionnistes et ce sont ces derniers
qui se sont pas mobilisés entre autres
aussi pour les élections régionales et
qui à mon avis vont faire mouche dans
l'est dans les semaines à venir et
aujourd'hui pourquoi pourquoi
omniprésent sur les plateaux dans les
analyses mais il n'est pas candidat
c'est ça devrait quand même faire une
marche et marine le pen pour vous c'est
cuit écoutez oui je pense qu on est
enfin je veux dire c'est que je veux
dire c'est que je vois là c'est pas
c'est pas mon sujet mais je pense que
face à un eric zemmour où il ya une
qualité il ya un fond il ya quelque
chose qui parle plus que qu'est ce qui a
manqué à marine le pen à lens pour
devenir président quelques à eric
zemmour eric zemmour je pense qu'il ya
une prière il ya une constance je pense
qu'il ya une culture générale qui est
pas besoin d'eux qu'ils étaient pas
besoin de la de la deûle à manifester
kwal elle sort un amour de l'histoire et
qui est et il est complètement scié
quand il explique quand il dit andrée
condensé son parcours de dont il vient
de montreuil pas une mode s etc et qui
est vrai qu'il a été et il démonte par
son parcours il s'est fait lui même vous
étiez très proche de jean marie le pen a
jeté bégon cameroun lui très proche
collaborateur en provence alpes côte
d'azur c'est ça je ne le renie
absolument pas et là vous avez une photo
qui était pour moi historique mais bien
que je suis étonné que vous ayez trouvé
c'est maintenant au tour de 19 cents
côté programme 8 j'avais évidemment
n'est pas plus de jeu j'étais plus jeune
que will smith mais j'ai en tout cas
c'est voilà donc ces samoyault pour vous
il faut marine le pen il avait une
chance d'être président à l'époque
écoutez moi je me suis engagé toujours
avec passion j'ai toujours la même
langue pour pour vous non il veut eric
zemmour s'est de nouveau jean marie le
pen ça n'a rien à voir enfin c'est en
tout cas il n'y aurait pas aujourd'hui
qu'on soit très clair un eric zemmour si
il n'y avait pas eu je pense un jean
marie le pen parce que c'est quand même
lui qui a porté un certain nombre
d'idées ou de
ou de ou d'attitudes qui a levé en tout
cas qui a levé depuis jean marie le pen
n'avait jamais admiré autant quelqu'un
je pense que oui je peux le dire
honnêtement oui je pense que j'ai pour
eric zemmour une
admiration parce que je trouve qu'il est
vous l'avez rencontrée je les vues de la
dernière fois il ya 20 ans et pour vous
dire il n'y a plus une vingtaine
d'années je crois grec et on s'était
retrouvés tous les deux chez une
connaissance commune d'un côté il y
avait un la famille de france côté
valois et de l'autre côté il y avait des
napoléons donc c'était l'union des deux
france à la fois les bonapartistes et
les légitimistes et il
y avait moyen bencher moule et je
ne sais pas si c'est très bien vous avez
raison c'est en tout cas et il faut que
je te le dire si certains ont eu encore
des doutes enfin en tout cas que se
posent des questions que vraiment être
français qu'elle soit très clair qu'on
arrête ce débat aussi aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas une couleur de peau ce n'est
pas une religion un set français sait
quelle que soit sa race sa religion sa
place à l'option philosophique et ça je
crois que aujourd'hui ce qui nous unit
tous ici c'est ça et c'est cette
histoire là parce que nous je veux dire
quand on se dit juste juste stéphane
vous trouvez pas qu'il est un petit peu
extremis parfois sur quelques idées eric
zemmour sur les prénoms sur sur l'islam
sur ça vous êtes d'accord actu et
surtout moi je ne trouve pas extrémiste
ou en tout cas je le trouve conservateur
met donc ça monsieur puisque je suis
moi-même un conservateur et je ne
nommerai pas que jean marie le pen y est
pas très conservateur moi je mets moi
j'ai toujours été conservateur je ne
sais plus grande expérience jamais été
ma vie d'extrême droite même si on l'a
voulu oui nous a comme la fumée de cette
connotation marie le pen n'était pas
invité au moins mais écoutez et jean
marie le pen je vais pas faire ce sont
100 pages le sont en général enfin je
veux dire il a été élu pour la première
fois député ses premiers pas mini table
il a été le premier parlementaire
français à être élu un compatriote
d'origine la wii à l'origine antillaise
que dossier jean marie le pen s'est
parlé de la guinée non mais si oui c'est
l'extrême droite
oui c'est parle monsieur le pen il était
pas texane droite le pen de sortir non
c'est pas que ça vient de sortir c'est
que je pense non mais écoutez il s'est
peut-être l'échiquier politique qui a
bougé mais lui je pense pas que pour moi
mais en tout cas comme eric zemmour ils
ont une conception de l'histoire très
révisionniste seller ception de
l'histoire il nous parle de vichy par
exemple c'est proche de ce que jean
marie lemoine disait n'était pas
particulièrement étonnant mais on peut
pas dire que la france de vichy elle a
sauvé des juifs par exemple combien est
bien à lui sinon un rapport qui était
plutôt proche de jean-marie le pen et
qui avait d'ailleurs particulièrement je
suis s'il vous plaît oui mais quand il
est vrai qu'il a sorti la parade et or
il est vu juste stéphane pont va pas
rentrer dans les détails voilà deux du
programme d'eric zemmour on l'a dit
voilà pour nous il ya vraiment des
choses qui peuvent déranger mais
aujourd'hui eric zemmour pour vous c'est
le candidat qui peut gagner bah écoutez
je pense que c'est le candidat qui peut
créer la surprise parce qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez vous étiez à droite pourquoi
pas voté pour didier bertrand pour
valérie pécresse bah écoutez le ci
pourquoi je ne répondais xavier bertrand
ça me pose un problème parce que ces
deux formations il est assureur vous
savez donc c'est la personne qui vous
fait j'avais un problème avec la maaf
[Rires]
c'est la personne qui vous fait signer
le petit papier en bas et puis vous avez
des petites klose s'est tous mis close
mais vous ne savez jamais les clauses
les étudie ces petits astérisques un
petit voilà donc les petits excès risque
donc voilà et puis quelqu'un qui prétend
donc qui prend un début de campagne qui
nous annonce a sur un ton très gaullien
en disant que c'est une relation
particulière entre le peuple et un
candidat et qui après quelques semaines
après ce don va jouer le jeu va se
présenter aux primaires déjà là il ya
déjà 1 à bandar justement voilà
justement mathieu louvain sept membres
du conseil national des républicains
alors vous êtes donc aux républicains
oui ce que regarder ça c'est hyper
intéressant mathieu c'est un cas d'école
donc vous êtes toujours membre du haut
conseil est toujours aux mains des
républicains et vous allez voter pour
eric zemmour lui au conseil national et
encore pas longtemps et j'étais celle
des jeunes républicains même en gironde
l'enclavé des responsables le
représentant des républicains c'est plus
ça va être plus calmes et bertrand
valérie pécresse en fait vous savez moi
ça fait neuf ans que je suis républicain
que je me dis tout républicain gerry
marrakech ont bravé
j'en ai 26 ans aujourd'hui quant à faire
neuf ans l'année prochaine les 26 ans
aujourd'hui j'ai démarré ou plus plutôt
jeune mais je me suis toujours intéressé
à la politique notamment à l'histoire et
j'ai toujours aussi subi un eczéma ou
même pendant mes engagements
républicains auprès d'autres candidats
notamment fillon en 2017 et donc moi je
me suis j'ai toujours été un passionné
d'histoire donc je partage aussi ses
deux passions avec eric zemmour avait pu
le rencontrer justement un dîner en 2019
cyril est
valorisée
organisé par eric tesnière justement et
et qui est rassemblé des militants des
jeunes républicains qui était venu
rencontrer regza moore discuter avec lui
de son livre le dessin français à
l'époque et justement je partage cette
passion l'histoire est calée dans cette
occasion là on avait discuté et ont
partagé beaucoup d'analysés historiques
et je vais pas sur vichy c'est pas le
sujet mais sur surnommé sujet justement
mathieu l'histoire est simple c'est que
vous êtes membre du conseil national des
républicains et vous avez décidé de
voter pour eric zemmour déjà comment ça
a été pris chez les républicains vous
savez chez les républicains il ya
toujours eu des tendances politiques
diverses tendances politiques là xavier
bertrand que vous avez montré dans le
dans les sondages il est plus haut
républicain
il a aujourd'hui ce titre il est au même
niveau car aisément tous les deux non
pas derrière elles ne sont pas adhérents
des républicains xavier bertrand a
quitté la république et en 2017 de
manière assez fracassante en critiquant
laurent wauquiez et les nommer les
nombreux militants médicaux alors en
grève on n'a jamais fait eric zemmour
critique une partie de la classe
dirigeante de la pluie qu'un qu'ils
jugent lâche et un jeu et rentrent chez
eux mais il n'a jamais critiqué les
militants qui d'ailleurs l'apprécié
énormément on regarde ses émissions le
lisent le suivent c'est aujourd'hui sont
nombreux à s'intéresser à la candidature
d'eric zemmour et même à nous rejoindre
monsieur disait que eric zemmour n'avait
pas de militants ski c'est pas vrai
aujourd'hui notamment chez les jeunes ya
3000 jeunes qui s'engagent tous les
jours auprès d'eric zemmour non à les
coller des affiches distribué des tracts
d'héripré valérie vaillant ça veut dire
que pour vous monsieur n'y a pas de
ligne infranchissable entre la droite
dite républicaine et la droite qu
incarne eric zemmour on pourrait
qualifier d'excellent de ses trophées à
l'époque chirac avait dit j'avais dit
qu'on l'a franchement c'est l'analyse
que ferries et moi alors mal déjà je
suis pas du tout chiraquien je me suis
jamais revendiqué de chirac j'ai
toujours plus haut apprécié des
personnalités comme charles pasqua ou
philippe séguin est finalement eric
zemmour le dit très bien il ya eu
justement aux républicains une forme de
centralisation du parti l'ump qui est
lancée des républicains en fait était la
réunion de l'udf qui était le parti du
centre et de l'erp et 1 qui était partie
de la droite le rpr s'est fait manger
par ses cadres par l'udf et on regarde
les pointus audition du héros dont les
années qui arrivent et c'est plein
régime elle souffre et vous voulez à
droite et plus adroits non mais regardez
laurent wauquiez a reçu eric zemmour en
2010 l'info république en lui disant
monsieur eric zemmour vous êtes chez
nous chez vous et eric zemmour de
pendant des années avant qu'il
s'intéresse à la vie politique active a
toujours été celle reçue avec 26 ans les
gens roulent et les élus des
républicains au contraire examen 26 ans
mathieu oui tout à fait et vous
intéresser et réglez vos preuves et eric
sont proposés les pouvoirs des cubicules
[Applaudissements]
j'avais 26 ans j'ai une vie j'ai une vie
en dehors de ma vie politique où je
m'amuse avec mes amis oui oui et oui
comme tout jeune homme de 26 ans est
aujourd'hui femme actuelle mais je crois
que la battue mais pourquoi eric zemmour
c'est pas parce que c'est pas parce que
vous aimez l'histoire si vous votez pour
votre prof d'histoire non j'explique
j'explique que j'aimerais pourquoi ce
eric zemmour j'ai une passion commune
avec eric zemmour j'ai des références
philosophiques des références et
historique intellectuelle qui me
cauchepin micex a devancé autres sinon
la peine de mort tu es aussi avec l'or
eric zemmour a pas dit qu'ils voulaient
rétabli la peine de mort je soutiens le
cefic moment il a il a dit que
philosophiquement elle était favorable
moi j'ai pas débattre sur la peine de
mort c'est pas le sujet des accords avec
lou géographique eric eric zemmour
pourquoi eric zemmour parce qu'il a
cette cohérence et cette constance dans
ses propos dans ses propositions
aujourd'hui moi j'ai soutenu des
candidats
qui ont proposé des choses au moment des
élections et qui au moment d'arriver au
pouvoir n'ont pas appliqué ce pourquoi
ils ont été élus
et les militants aujourd'hui le remarque
le partage de ce constat avec moi je
discute encore beaucoup avec des
militants g élus dans les instances des
républicains par les médias fait votre
choix ce sera eric zemmour c'est sûr ou
à oui ça serait j'ai fait mon choix
c'est risible aujourd'hui les candidats
potentiels à la pluie qu'un c'est xavier
bertrand qui a quitté le parti en
critiquant les militants nous traitant
de facho ou deux personnes qui courions
derrière l'extrême droite c'est valérie
pécresse qui a fait le même constat que
des bertrand sur les militants des
républicains qui est aussi qu'ils
étaient partis michel barnier qui a
encore un mois défendez l'européisme
d'emmanuel macro et grégory des rallyes
chez l'européen et qui aujourd'hui
reprend les thèmes dérision
finalement on regarde ce qui se passe à
droite aujourd'hui dans l'élection tous
essayé de reprendre les thématiques et
les idées d'eric zemmour car ils
comprennent qu est-ce que c'est ce qui
touche aux électeurs de droite et les
militants je vais régime et gilles
monsieur excusez moi mais est ce que
vous n'avez pas un opportuniste est ce
que pour répondre à la question vous
n'êtes pas en train de vous rendre
compte que zemmour exploit non un droit
alors que les républicains mais ce que
les républicains c'est mort pour cette
élection pourquoi tu es marié n'était
pas sûr que ça soit mort mais l'audit
les bandas se rendront alors non la mort
vous vous dites moi le match à leur
chance de gagner ses deux fils jumeaux
alors c'est une critique que je refuse
totalement et je trouve même
désobligeantes parce que c'est pas du
tout le sens de mon engagement depuis
que je suis je suis engagé en politique
je me suis toujours engagé en politique
pour des idées pour pour la défense du
nid d'une idée d'une vision de la france
et vous savez j'ai commencé à soutenir
les zemmour il était crédité a même pas
5% dans les sondages il est écrit
c'était en début en début février
j'étais venu déjà partis chez les amis
d'eric zemmour pour commencer à créer
une structure qui permettrait à eric
zemmour d'être candidat s'il le voulait
et qui incite et règlements et qu'on a
j'ai jamais voulu être élu j'ai jamais
demandé à être élu dans n'importe quelle
élection on m'a fait des propositions
vous allez quitter vous allez tourner
comme a fait des propositions et encore
récemment les démissionnaires donné
d'aller vous avez jamais les
républicains s'étaient quittés
république et non non non je suis
attaché à ma femme moderne mes bras
quand je galère je suis l'autre mof a
donné ce nom mais vous savez
non mais je vous invite à venir un jour
j'ai pas dire à ma femme j'ai envie de
bp shoah mais je reviens quand même ce
soir non mais je vous invite à venir un
jour dans les partis politiques pour
voir comment ça se passe salut dans les
partis politiques c'est comme une
famille il ya les militants ou avec qui
on discute avec qui on partage des
choses il ya quelque chose d'humain dans
les parties publiques et après il ya la
dimension politique où il ya toujours
des guerres d'influencé des désaccords
sur certains sujets et qui par moments
avec la direction n'est pas toujours
d'accord avec la direction actuelle
quand laurent wauquiez était le
président des républicains j'étais
totalement en phase avec laurent
wauquiez quand françois xavier bellamy
était candidat aux européennes j'étais
totalement en phase avec françois
gallier bellamy est aujourd'hui ces
personnalités la échange avec eric
zemmour et sont potentiellement des
personnes qui rejoindront eric zemmour
quand il sera déclaré qu'en dira oui
vous voulez des idées des mots mais pour
vous c'est quoi des cinq grandes idées
que défend l'un d'eux mêmes de
d'ailleurs même de donner des débats et
juste là donnez moi cinq grandes idées
tu veux en donner
cinq joueurs de l'équipe de france
alors fait cinq fruits et légumes vapeur
tue aussi passé beaucoup donc faut aussi
parler de foot sont alors maintenant on
va alors lui donner deux grandes idées à
l'examen des restes c'est l'amour de la
france et croire que la france n'est pas
avec tout le monde aime la france
tu crois que tu as roma avoir à cognac
qui a joué deux présidents mais je peux
pas voir ce billet
c'est
madame au bono sur ce plateau je suis
désolé pour moi madame aubenas n'est pas
quelqu'un qui aime la france dans sa
dimension elle a les bras là pour ça
n'allait pas
d'accès direct est mort eric zemmour
crois que la france c'est tout mais
c'est la continuité d'une histoire la
continuité d'une culture à la continuité
d'une civilisation je partage libre de
transit à charles martel saison gruda on
parle de clovis non
j'ai pas le livre sur moi même mais je
vous inviterai à mal un peu les nous c
est devenu ce qu'il est donc l'amour de
la france l'amour de la france l'amour
du maillot et l'amour du maillot si on
veut c'est la mort la fatwa est alors
prêt il croit également que la france
est une civilisation
la souplesse on la retrouve là on
intervient pas roulé sur déroulés ces
cinq sites sur le christ et
civilisations ok c'était pas la parole
et si les terrains dits d'accord et il
croit également que pour parler
d'économie que la france doit voir levée
économiquement notamment verizon les
charges sociales en baissant les charges
sociales et en limitant les aides
sociales on va dire aux étrangers pour
pouvoir les favorisés aux
nationaux d'accord ouais dernière le
jury dès la 4eme la quatrième idée c'est
de croire que la france et les français
sont une culture à défendre et quelques
aujourd'hui elle est en danger de mort
qu'elle est menacée par différentes
différentes choses que ce soit le
basculement démographique que ça soit à
l'islamisation danser dans certains
quartiers aient aussi insécurité la c1
finalement et oui mais est donc faux de
vos cinq idées à chaque fois le sous
titre c'est la faute des étrangers
voilà même si j'ai un physique à chaque
série jusqu'à le même il n'est pas
d'accord on étudie aide sociaux aux
étrangers calmement êtres sociaux aux
étrangers ça veut dire même être sociaux
étrangers qui travaillent on leur enlève
les aides sociales
c'est sûr mais qui ne sait pas ce que ça
vous ennuie vu que c'est doit permettre
de tout non il te plait normand n'est
pas en magasin il sait on brade sociaux
on est où là
est ce qu'il y aura des chevals au
gouvernement
le colosse
[Applaudissements]
merde
alors est-ce que vous croisez aa
c'est la chronique aux adultes est ce
que vous croyez
vous qu'il y aura des êtres sociaux
alors eric zemmour justement ap est pas
est passé sur lci je sais pas si c'est
si vous l'avez vu ou pas microtech mais
justement pour parler et non le
notamment d'économie ou c'est un sujet
on l'attaquent régulièrement disant
qu'il n'a pas de proposition économie il
ne s'est pas débattre d'économies et
justement il a montré durant ce débat
récemment parlé qui connaissait le sujet
et tu pouvais être capable de présenter
des propositions un problème plus quand
il parle de retirer les aides sociales
aux étrangers est souvent
vous plairait c'est pour ces pour les
étrangers qui ne cotisent pas et qu'un
luxueux qui sont inactifs aujourd'hui la
part d'étrangers qu'il fait une actu on
lui enlève ces êtres sensibles et non
pas ce qu'il a dit les français le
français mathieu faut tisser français
dont il peut bénéficier un droit ils
peuvent bel il peut bénéficier de l'aide
nationale et de d'accord on peut générer
quelques jours deviennent des quartiers
à 2 millions de cartes n'est pas d'un
terrien qui circulent qui sont fausses
il est peut-être normal peut-être un
moment donné peut-être dans les tv et
apprenez tous les gens qui ont plus de
50 ans a pu se trouve de l'autre côté de
la méditerranée je suis moi c'est quoi
cette histoire de cabrito aller 2 2
[Applaudissements]
pour y revenir
aujourd'hui il ya 40% d'étrangers qui
sont inactifs donc ils ne cotisent pas
on est toujours sur les étrangers
pour passer à autre chose avec grand
taux plein va faire monter et
montesquieu les lettres personnes non la
cia 40 pour ces délits qui sont inactifs
et qui ne cotisent pas pour 10% de
nationaux de français qui sont inactifs
et une cote histoire ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui qu'il ya une grande sortie
défense et l'espace il ya un français
sur deux qui vient d'ici à 10 % de
français inactifs hamon oui il ya 10 %
d'étrangers les 40% d'étrangers qui se
saluent aujourd'hui on constate qu'il ya
aujourd'hui vous pouvez vérifier les
chiffres et en sortant il va les
vérifier t'inquiète est hyper il a un
nom mais je suis convaincu que c'est du
super u à lui et moi encore un peu aussi
durant son débat lci qui ont été
vérifiés et acceptée et donc on se rend
compte aujourd'hui une grande partie des
français en fait cotisent pour des pour
une partie des étrangers une
presqu'île presque la moitié des
étrangers qui lui en france ils sont
inactifs et qui ne cotisent pas et du
coup qui bénéficient de l'aide nationale
alors qu'ils sont même pas juste est ce
que est ce qu est ce que pour toi parce
que c'est la question qu'on se pose je
vais le tutoyer tout lentement nous on
le savait mais dans la dark
afin de les amis d'eric zemmour va
falloir changer le nom de l'émission en
tp nzz am aux émois aulas hamas ça c'est
bien ça c'est alors ils sont tous
contents de moi c'était ça me touche pas
mon job
[Applaudissements]